un client à la fois blandine mille voix
son épicerie 0 des chefs prendre son
envol une entreprise qui n'était qu'un
projet lorsque la pandémie a commencé au
printemps dernier est-ce qu'on va
vraiment s'embarquer à ouvrir une
épicerie à emprunter de l'argent a signé
un bail pour cinq ans alors qu'on sait
pas du tout ce qui va se passer la
semaine prochaine
après réflexion blandine et océane bart
ont remis leur projet sur les rails
l'épicerie locaux voient le jour en
septembre grâce à un prêt commercial de
200 mille dollars
on sent que les gens ou en vie nous
soutenir vraiment beaucoup
justement il ya beaucoup de valeur
environnementale les valeurs locales
vraiment qu'ils ont été très importantes
pendant la pandémie
elle tente aussi d'aider des
restaurateurs qui cherche à se
renouveler
ici on avait prêtes à manger des plats
pour emporter c'est ce sur quoi on mise
chez basilico pizza il y avait une panne
et alfredo al-zaidi viennent d'ouvrir ce
petit restaurant sur l'île des soeurs
ils venaient tous les deux de perdre
leur emploi dans un autre restaurant du
quartier très beaucoup des risques mais
il n'a pas de choix
si je reste sans travail ce que je dois
faire parmi ces risques des prêts
personnels totalisant 50 mille dollars
pour aménager les locaux puisque aucune
banque n'a voulu leur accorder un prêt
commercial en a acheté sa prison acheter
de l'équipement arabe et de restaurants
qui fermait et repousse des dépenses
comme l'achat d'une affiche à l'entrée
si la pandémie pose des défis elle crée
aussi des occasions dit cet expert
regardez ce qui se passe il va avoir un
grand choix moi je vous dire si
quelqu'un en ce moment doit signer un
bail
il a le bon bout du bâton pour négocier
toutes les clauses de ce bail là et ce
alors que les habitudes des
consommateurs sont chamboulés par le
virus invisible ici m caron radio canada
montréal